[Applause]
[Music]
angela merkel is something like the king
arthur of politics now that she's
retiring it seems that the whole of
europe will be without direction can we
really imagine a future without merkel
many of you watching this video may not
even have political memories of what
europe was like before merkel we are
talking about one of the longest serving
democratic leaders in office 16 years
during her career as german chancellor
merkel has met four different u.s
presidents within germany there is only
one other politician who has lasted so
long as chancellor helmut khal but
that's not all angela merkel leaves
office with an enviable popularity an
impressive 76 percent of germans still
trust her despite having been in power
for so long and according to all the
polls she is the world's most highly
rated leader in all other countries in
other words no matter whether you like
angela merkel or not one thing is
certain our children are going to study
her in their history textbooks and the
comparison seems obvious are we dealing
with a new margaret thatcher
[Music]
after all both merkel and thatcher were
the first women presidents of their
respective countries both belonged to
center-right parties both won several
elections and both established
themselves as great world leaders the
difference is that thatcher always had
more of a polarizing profile in the case
of merkel we could say that everybody
loves her everyone loves her like a
friend
social democrats narrowly beat angela
merkel's alliance and historic german
election that's right when margaret
thatcher left power the british people
re-elected a candidate from her own
party the conservative john major
however merkel has not succeeded in
getting her successor to win their
elections again it's not that germans
are entirely disappointed with her but
it seems that they've had enough of
christian democracy in this video we're
going through merkel's main highs and
lows what merkel has done wrong and
where she's missed the mark what is
angela merkel's legacy how will she be
remembered today we're going to answer
these questions but first let's take a
look at a bit of history
[Music]
don't touch what's working
to understand merkel's political legacy
we have to understand the legacy left to
her by the previous chancellor we are
talking about the social democrat
gerhard schroeder
yes the name is probably going to sound
familiar to many of you especially to
those of you who are veteran followers
of visualpolitik because we have talked
about him quite a lot on this channel
and usually not in a very positive light
schroder was a chancellor of germany and
since then he has been working for the
russian gas company gazprom but let's be
honest even if schroder is currently
putin's man in europe you have to admit
that he was not a bad chancellor of
germany
[Music]
one of his great achievements was agenda
2010 a kind of macro labor reform
designed to get germany out of the
crisis in which it found itself we're
talking about the beginning of the 21st
century at that time germany was the
lame duck of europe unemployment was
above 8
so schroeder's labor reform included
huge privatizations flexibility of
procedures and all those things that
typically make unions angry and you know
what this time it was no different the
opposition schroeder faced was so fierce
that in 2005 he lost a no-confidence
motion yes that's right the german labor
reform cost mr schroder his job that's
how in 2005 germany held early elections
and that's when the protagonist of this
video comes into the picture
merkel becomes germany's first woman
chancellor so what happened as soon as
merkel came to power well that whole
package of labor reforms that the
previous government had just approved it
started to take effect you don't believe
me well just take a look at this graph
[Music]
as you can see the first year after the
adoption of agenda 2010 unemployment
peaks think of it this way reforms do
not work immediately but from 2005
onwards unemployment started to fall in
other words schroeder suffered the bad
part of making unpopular policies which
is they are unpopular merkel however
reaped the reward which is that they
worked but not only that think about it
the german economy is one of the most
diversified in the world we've talked
about it a thousand times here on
visualpolitik germany has thousands of
medium-sized companies that are leaders
in their niche markets we're not talking
about famous companies but for example
have you ever wondered who makes the
souls on your shoes well most probably
the rubber sole of your shoe is made by
a company called desma practically no
one has heard of it but in its niche it
is the world leader germany has
thousands of cases like this
[Music]
and that combined with schroder's labor
policies led to germany surviving the
financial crisis of 2008 better than
anyone else and who was governing
germany at that time that's right angela
merkel of course we don't want to take
all the credit away from her the fact
that she did not mess with something
that was already working is to be
applauded but we are not talking only
about the economy in fact another of
merkel's big gambles was the energy
policy you see since the 1980s germany
has been one of the most anti-nuclear
countries in the world in fact
chancellor gerhard schroeder as a good
leftist wanted to close all nuclear
reactors in the country as you can
imagine merkel as a good right winger
totally disagreed pay attention to what
she said in 2009
merkel on defensive over nuclear power
angela merkel the german chancellor is
campaigning to reverse the decision to
phase out nuclear energy by 2021 if her
favorite center-right coalition option
takes power however that is what she was
advocating in 2009. two years later
japan suffered the fukushima accident
and i know what many of you are thinking
what does japan have to do with germany
well if we go into the details not much
but as you know details science and data
matter little in politics by 2011 being
pro-nuclear in germany was totally
unpopular check it out hundreds of
thousands protest against nuclear energy
across germany yes indeed this is how
merkel went from defending nuclear power
to announcing the shutdown of nuclear
reactors as soon as possible today
germany has shut down almost all of its
reactors as of today only six remain in
this case we're talking about a policy
that has been very popular but has had
catastrophic consequences
[Music]
on the one hand by abandoning nuclear
power germany has had to burn more coal
secondly germany has had to resort to
natural gas from russia we have
discussed all this in depth in other
visualpolitik videos but broadly
speaking we could define germany's
energy policy as quiet populism yes it's
true merkel has always been honest and
has never made grand passionate speeches
but in many cases she has let herself be
guided more by opinion polls than by
data fortunately for merkel the
consequences of her energy policy will
not be borne by her but by her successor
take a look
german households face 11.5 percent rise
in gas bills but that's a topic for
another video now let's focus on another
fundamental aspect of merkel her role in
international politics let's take a
closer look
the art of making agreements
to understand merkel well we have to
understand a very important concept
political capital political capital is
the credibility that a leader has in
front of his or her voters or in front
of other leaders this credibility can be
invested to take more or less risky
decisions or to persuade other
politicians to reach agreements well you
could say that angela merkel is the jeff
bezos of political capital for example
we have the case of the 2011 euro crisis
do you remember that germany was one of
the countries that had come out of the
financial crisis reasonably well off to
make a comparison when spain was
exceeding 26 unemployment germany was at
2.4 percent
in those years the countries of southern
europe were known as the pigs that's an
acronym for portugal italy greece and
spain these four countries needed to
finance themselves the markets demanded
very high interest rates because
investors were not confident that they
could recover their debts they had only
one alternative to ask for help from the
european union and what was the largest
economy in europe and which was also one
of the best off germany and who was the
german chancellor at that time exactly
protesters rally as merkel voices
support for austerity hit greece that is
how the legend of merkel was born the
champion of austerity and what does
austerity mean well basically merkel was
willing to lend money to the countries
of southern europe at low interest rates
however she demanded that those same
countries commit themselves to pay it
back and in order to do so they had to
show that they were going to cut costs
[Music]
as you can imagine these were very
unpopular measures no politician wants
to have to lay off civil servants and
that's how almost overnight all of us
europeans found ourselves with hundreds
of caricatures of merkel as the strict
german who wants to force the poor
spaniards and greeks to tighten their
belts and you're probably wondering did
the pigs really come to accept austerity
well on paper yes now in reality there
are a lot of interpretations to be made
there for example spain committed itself
to making cuts while simultaneously
doing things like this
madrid 2020 presents its olympic bid in
switzerland that's right while spain
promised not to waste any more money
madrid wanted to host the olympic games
which as everyone knows are anything but
cheap and games that by the way were
going to be the 2020 olympics the ones
that almost ruined japan seems that
spain dodged a bullet there actually in
any case did merkel really succeed in
seducing southern europe with austerity
well yes and no some countries like
portugal have followed myrtle's formula
greece has implemented some cuts but
neither spain nor italy has embraced
austerity
in other words in the end wealthy europe
ended up making a capital transfer with
almost no strings attached the question
is did merkel make a good deal or could
she have made more of her political
capital we'll leave that to personal
opinion but the truth is that this has
not been the only major crisis led by
merkel listen up
number of refugees to europe seeking
asylum surges to record 1.3 million in
2015. the war in syria resulted in
millions of refugees knocking on
europe's doors and this is how one of
the most intense debates in the european
union began can we accept so many people
who come without work and with such a
different culture in this case merkel
was clear
angela merkel defends germany accepting
10 000 un refugees in this case merkel
had to go up against all the easternmost
countries of the european union but also
within germany she encountered many
sectors that were not in favour of
accepting refugees she was even
criticized within her own party think
about it we are talking about thousands
of refugees who need to be fed given a
house and taught the language just so
they can integrate you know that here on
visualpolitik we have always been in
favor of immigration but the refugee
crisis does have so many nuances and it
is logical that many people were against
it
[Music]
in fact it could be argued that merkel's
stance was the push the most nationalist
german right needed to get into
parliament since then alternative for
germany has become one of the most
important parties in the country anyway
it must be acknowledged that in this
case merkel stood up for her principles
and got many other countries in europe
to follow in her footsteps the question
is was she really following her
principles or was she following the
opinion polls well we'll take a look at
that right now
[Music]
why merkel is not thatcher
i know what many of you are thinking
we've been talking about merkel for
several minutes now and we still haven't
even talked about the coronavirus
exactly the crowning achievement of the
merkle administration has been its
handling of the coronavirus pandemic and
why you may ask if you look at germany's
numbers you will see that they are not
particularly bad but not particularly
good either there are many other
countries like taiwan or south korea
that have done much better however at a
time when almost no european leader has
measured up merkel seemed to be the only
one who had a clear strategy not only
that she has also been one of the few
cases of honesty that we've seen when
she has had to deliver bad news she has
not hesitated for a moment all of this
created an enviable personality and
leadership style and that is precisely
the most remarkable thing about merkel
are you looking for a role model in your
life imitate merkel
the question the real question is what
was merkel's great political project and
this is where it's inevitable that we
enter into the realm of comparisons i
know that comparisons are odious and
sometimes they are necessary and now
it's time to put angela merkel's profile
next to that of margaret thatcher
[Music]
the big difference is that margaret
thatcher never had to govern in a
coalition during the 11 years of her
administration thatcher had a free hand
to decide on her own merkel however has
never governed alone first she had to
ally herself with the social democrats
then with the social democrats again in
other words she has had to make many
concessions but the question remains
what principles does merkel have i mean
we could criticize many things about
thatcher's legacy but we all know what
her principles were and she defended
them to the end in merkel's case it is
almost impossible to understand what her
political project was for example in
2015 merkel was saying this about
refugees
if europe fails on the question of
refugees then it won't be the europe we
wished for angela merkel however this is
what angela merkel herself said just
years before that
angela merkel german multiculturalism
has utterly failed i know what many of
you will say everyone has the right to
change their mind that is true the
question is are we talking about a
change of opinion or an attempt to
please the voters we find something
similar with her energy policy when
merkel was running in her first election
her party advocated keeping nuclear
power plants it only took a few
demonstrations and opinion polls for
merkel to announce the closure of all
reactors from one day to the next
[Music]
and we are not talking about a minor
issue without nuclear power germany has
had to rely even more on natural gas and
as you know if you follow visualpolitik
almost all of that natural gas comes
from russia what's more do you remember
gerhard schroeder we said that you can't
understand merkel without understanding
schrodinger and the truth is that the
careers of these two politicians have
always gone hand in hand because just
now in 2021 the interests of schroder
who works for gazprom and those of
merkel have come together once again
[Music]
gazprom announces that its nordstrom 2
gas pipeline to germany is finished i
doubt very much that ukrainians are very
fond of merkel quite the opposite
nordstrom 2 has made germany and the
whole of europe even more dependent on
russia and all because of an energy
policy that was not backed by any
scientific data only political and
parliamentary arithmetic
[Music]
in other words we cannot deny that
merkel has had the charisma and an
ability to adapt to events worthy of
applause but has she really had a clear
political project that is more debatable
but now the question is over to you how
do you think we will remember merkel
what lessons should the politicians who
are still active learn from this leader
you can leave me your answers in the
comments and as always don't forget that
here on visualpolitik we release new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel and hit the little bell icon so
you don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video then of course like it
and i'll see you in the next one take
care see you soon
[Music]